j'étais dubaï on va revenir sur toutes
les dernières infos qui me soit tombé
sous la main vous savez je suis
maintenant un journaliste qui investigue
s'investit beaucoup je vous le dis et
c'est probablement le plus gros coup de
gueule de ces derniers jours la
fédération française de naturisme s'est
emporté car facebook a décidé de
supprimer sa page
on vous explique tout ça jamais pleuré
tout le week end en tunisie
j'étais pas bien du tout regardez quand
il s'agit de censure et de nudité les
principaux réseaux sociaux font rarement
preuve d'une grande tolérance
une fois encore ils l'ont prouvé et
cette fois ci c'est facebook qui s'en
est pris aux naturistes
alors que la page la vie au soleil
permet depuis des années aux naturistes
de france de rester connecter le réseau
social de mark zuckerberg a décidé de
mettre fin à cet outil de communication
de vue selon eux inapproprié une
fermeture dont a été victime également
la page consacrée à la fédération
française de naturisme
une décision qui a provoqué la colère de
la présidente de la fédération assimilé
à de la pornographie notre art de vivre
a été bloqué le naturisme ne peut et ne
doit pas être associée à la pornographie
le naturisme une pratique qui regroupe
tout de même plus de 17 millions
d'adeptes à travers le monde
et là la fédération française de
naturisme a réagi auprès de jean marc
morandini vous le dis est ce que vous
trouvez ça franchement 16 oui j moi je
suis extrêmement choquée j'ai déjà fait
du naturisme bien sûr mais quelle
horreur
2 millions de pratiquants il ya deux
millions de personnes qui pratiquent le
naturisme en france et donc supprimer
cette page facebook et l'assimiler à la
pornographie
je ne comprends pas d'autant qu'il y
avait de l'assemblée générale des
naturistes c'est une pâte très suivie je
ne comparerai du naturisme doc gynéco
n'ont jamais tu t'es jamais fumé tout nu
sur une plage nord s'était déjà mis tout
nu rarement j'ai quand même pas deux
fois par jour tout nu ah oui seulement
tellement quoi seulement seulement dans
le bain une fois par mois les jours je
prends pas des douches
tu prends des ben ouais valoir sa webapp
attention de pas t'endormir de nom mais
ça rigolait georges fume des cigares
dans le bain cigarette dans les bars web
tels que fumer est dangereux pour la
santé que je fume des cigarettes dans le
bain ouais ouais avec toi tu dois rester
des heures et des heures
oui je trouve un peu surprenant d'autant
plus qu il yad autres d'autres pages
facebook sur le naturisme qui reste pas
de rester ouvert et il ne montre ni sexe
ni poitrine sur leur site donc c'est une
assez surprenant il n'empêche 9,6 mais
d'ici là finir oui voilà et ils disent
en fait que c'est parce que les règles
de facebook sont de plus en plus accrue
mais ne comprennent pas ce qui s'est
passé
geneviève est ce que tout a déjà fait
d'une nature et ont beaucoup de bons
[Musique]
jeunes a déjà fait du naturisme
non est ce que tu es pour les plages
naturistes toi ben watt chacun sait ce
qui se veut à la guerre leurs frites un
mois c'est pas bon c'est pas mon univers
mais pourquoi pas du marquage par existe
depuis du côté d'arcachon il ya des
plages quel genre de méthode j'aimerais
saluer mois de choc tellement monstrueux
mais ça te choque toi mais ça me choque
pas mais ça me ça me concerne pas avait
chacun fait cela sa bulle avec leur
freedom en pouvant varier à moi bah on
ne me demande pas de me déshabiller
dax à vous temp années free free allait
rejeter les exhibitions comme ça pour la
télévision ça il faut bien qu'ils
trouvent des nouveaux sujets vous avez
répondu non je trouve pas ça très
esthétique ah ouais cérébral un oui je
trouve alors j'ai une deuxième info qui
est complètement folle hélas elle vous
concerne un petit peu jean-michel via
une application improbable dans
l'émission tout compte fait diffusé sur
france 2 on a rencontré un homme qui a
souhaité rester anonyme
il explique qu'il était persuadé que sa
femme le trompait et pour en être sûr
il a trouvé une application qui lui a
permis d'avoir accès à distance au
message envoyé par sa femme bien sûr
d'horreur regardé et je vous le dis quoi
qu'ils aient fait encore vous n'avez pas
reçu une photo and on and on que ce que
vous avez fait vous avez ouvert
regardez mais non si l'on se jette sur
cet abonnement à 15 euros par mois
après avoir créé un compte il choisit
une pièce jointe dans laquelle sera
caché un virus le jeune homme n'a plus
qu envoyé la photo piéger en l'ouvrant
sa conjointe installe sans le savoir le
logiciel espion sur son téléphone
désormais dès qu'elle reçoit un nouveau
message six mois on a une copie hélas
ils voulaient tous tout s'accélère
j'ai accès à plus d'informations et je
veux n'en compte que comme je vous ai
dit précédemment que sont avérées qui
est entrepris alors voilà c'est
complètement fou ce que vous avez
espionner votre mari épousé mien un
logiciel espion dans le minitel bd mon
mari est lui serait bien foutu de le
faire parce qu'ils perdent tout le temps
son téléphone
vous êtes jalouses si jalouse mais je
suis contre franchement ce genre de
pratique alors est-ce qu'il ya quand
même un lien de confiance mais ça se
sent quand la personne est pas clair
verdict de leur mort puisque moi je vous
le dis j'ai des sms des chroniqueurs non
je te jure petite affaire banon annonce
assis baroud a regardé par exemple j'ai
la conversation que maxime a eu il ya
pas longtemps avec son banquier
si j'ai fait que sa sortie sortez pas
sorti pourquoi parce que je viens de le
décider à les sortir j'aimerais avoir un
rendez vous pour vous cette action
banquiers bonjour maxime êtes vous
toujours payé par cyrine oui non c'est
moche avec journée à notre regard des
j'ai découvert que jean mi a contacté as
many sur what's app narrer oui ah oui ça
lui c'est jean-michel je peux te
demander un truc oui du moment que tu me
donnes pas de faire l'amour avec toi et
devoir retrouver le top 5 des raisons
qui pousse une personne à être infidèle
ah oui comme dans une famille en or vous
allez me faire des propositions qui
pousse une personne à tromper son
partenaire
si vous avez les 5 bonnes réponses vous
doublez tous notre salaire aujourd'hui
attention non on part parce que si vous
avez trois croix c'est terminé c'est
tout et je ne veux monter sur vos joker
on peut donner des réponses
et moi j'ai voté ciu qu'est ce qui
pousse à être infidèle l'ex le manque de
confiance
le manque de confiance non manque de
confiance non une croix on va faire le
tour merci doc gynéco d'attention le
manque d' alfonso le manque d'attention
alors la fois plus petit en plein régime
le manque d'attention n'avez vous mettez
en rogne hommes voilà merci encore à une
croix pour vous si vous avez trois croix
s'est perdu matthieu delormeau et moi ah
oui pardon à la jalousie calme-toi
calme-toi la coopama
mais quel rapport
qu'est ce qui pousse cac 40 en asie elle
a dit la jalousie jalousie c'est bien
joli génie conseil a pas la balance
consultant ses débuts la six matches
qu'on a tiré par quelqu'un arrivera bien
sûr par quels canaux
oui et spécialiste de la mort la forte
attirance coutume ok mais non c'est la
seule locaux oui pour se sentir plus
attirant
[Applaudissements]
et
alors est-ce que vous avez vu
oui
[Musique]
allez on va mal aimé terminer car c'est
que je suis fou l'attirance et en y
avait quand je pense en quatrième
position allez-y bravo en tout cas c'est
très bien c'est pour tester de nouvelles
choses très bien
troisième position par lâcheté manque de
courage en deuxième position on se
sentir plus attirant et en première
place et la raison qu elle passait là
oui c'est moi allez voir votre mari
liban n'est pas venu ça vous faire un
peu de lait le temps c'est pas ne tentez
pas de l'ataxie de van et fait attention
c'est vrai mais ça s'accélère
[Rires]
là on le sait les transferts de thomas
vergara et dernièrement sur les réseaux
à la publie une petite vidéo dans
laquelle elle se pose des questions
vraiment existentielles sur sa grossesse
et sur son bébé y regarder c'est du
grand habit donc un truc que je
comprends bien que quand je fais un bain
ont révélé deux fois dans look non mais
il est une fois dans l'eau dans mon
ventre et une autre fois dans l'eau dans
le banc et le truc que je me demande
c'est genre comment il fait pour
respirer
alors oui coque vous qu'êtes docteur doc
gynéco vous avez peut-être pouvoir
éclairer nabila et d'autres futures
mamans qui n'ont qu'un tout d'abord est
ce que vous pouvez expliquer à nabila
pourquoi son bébé n'est pas vraiment
deux fois dans l'eau est-ce qu'il serait
deux fois dans l'eau elle elle ressent
comme ça elle le ressens comme ça mais
je vous êtes docteur non douay voulu
dire comment le bébé peut respirer dans
le bain mais il avait les à combien de
mois
cc c'est du lourd est-ce qu'on est à
l'état embryonnaire ou est-ce qui est ce
qu'il est déjà les panais et là quelques
mois déjà
soyez tranier il est dans son ventre
l enceinte nabila je crois qu'il respire
par le nez non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le 4 h 30
des gens qui savent pas que quand
l'enfant sort souvent le donne une
claque sur les fesses pour faire crier
ce que c'est au client qui l'ébranlé
bronches ex nice s'ouvre et du coup il
peut respirer
alors on va fonctionner que les autres à
fond on a appris que des livreurs d'une
marque alimentaire qui commence par free
et qui finit par jeter proposer aux
clients des services un peu particulier
regardez certains livreurs ont en effet
laissé au fond des sacs de livraison des
numéros de téléphone pour commander
quelque chose regardez geneviève
regarder ça va pas vous perdre sa garde
un plateau repas commandés sur internet
puis livré quelques minutes plus tard
mais à l'ouverture du sac une carte de
visite avec un numéro de téléphone
et cette inscription intéressé cocaïne
cette scène se déroulait début février
dans nos locaux après que l'un de nos
journalistes et commander son déjeuner
c'est bien le livreur en uniforme d'une
société de livraison bien connu qui a
glissé cette carte dans ce sac et si
l'entreprise n'est en rien responsable
mais victime de l'acte personnel de l'un
de ces livreurs la pratique n'étonne pas
les forces de l'ordre selon
l'observatoire français des drogues et
toxicomanies le nombre de français
consommateurs de cocaïne a été multiplié
par deux en moins de dix ans c'est pas
grave
sainte-geneviève hélas hélas alaoui 1
franchement non mais il ya est ce que
dit la vérité est ce qu'il ya ce que tu
as déjà pu voir la drogue sur le voilà
sur sur l'ailé voilà les élections de
miss ans s'entraîne jamais nom est sûre
non nous on a les images
oui c'est pas bien évidemment la
suspicion sur l'ensemble d'exactement
wes ans livreur qui travaillent
énormément d'en découvrir très difficile
voilà c'est sont pas faire une
généralité l'extrême majorité d'entre
eux sont parfaits on a travaillé très
dur et rieur édifie qu'on les embrasse
fort payant